tee's Chris long how are you Chris elder
I am doing better for chatting with you
appreciate you you calling in um let's
let's start I guess first and foremost
with you where you are watching the
events unfold in your hometown and in
your your college campus years where
were you watching what was unfolding in
Charlottesville Chris yeah I mean hard
week was a hard week for you know
America in general but you know being
from sure he'll being a tight-knit
community so no not a community that
wants to stand for the timer I hate that
was going to be there I think anybody
that played at Virginia or grew up in
Charlotte or was in trouble currently
was pretty disturbed by that and you
know for me being at rest camp I
couldn't be very CUTE support the
wonderful collection of people from in
times amount of time that were defending
you know our fellow Americans and timon
also so I had to kind of watch TV or you
know check the news compile the time
during breaks in my meetings you know
how career camp finishes up there eight
or nine o'clock trying to catch up on
what went down that day and just was
left alone it's quite an angry and
helpless and I told everybody but my
neck of the woods feels that way and
hopefully Americans feel that way so
that gives you a little Slovakian now it
might feel sometimes to be the subject
of that hey well I mean your dad gave
voice to that earlier this week when he
was on here saying that he and your mom
hand-picked Charlottesville is a place
to to raise you and and your siblings
and how difficult it is that this name
of the city is now associated with the
violence that took place last week just
for the mere fact that this is where the
fascists and neo-nazis chose to show
their faces in the 21st century Chris
and you know what was it like growing up
there well
it's home for me still it's where I plan
on raising a family you know my son
wailing you know walks around right
where all that stuff went down and
that's what men should uh even hit home
a little bit more and you know Canada is
as selfish as it is to just think it's
just about colorful because if you feel
violated when you see that type of trans
mentality hopefully French mentality
everyone knows at this point but uh in
our country kind of manifests itself in
one place and it happened in your
hometown you feel violated for sure but
yes my mind yourself is one really about
Charlotte Ville it's about America and
the fact that this stuff even exists it
doesn't make it any more acceptable too
often in my hometown or at home Canon
you know it might be for something or
you can see the wait for the issues that
are going on in our country it's it's an
extra wake-up call Chris long and the
Philadelphia Eagles joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show let's turn to last
night um how did you uh how did you set
up I guess if you will what you were
doing with Malcolm or what Malcolm was
going to do and how you joined him Chris
how did you coach that you know
obviously this is a hot hot button topic
where everybody has to take on you know
the national anthem and our flag and
some of the protests that have occurred
during it and you know I'm one of those
people that have said always you can
call it a compound if you want but I'm
just speaking the truth which is all I
was ever kneel to the anthem but I have
respected the activism and action that
somebody like Colin has taken off the
sea all the way from an anthem started
the conversation he's he's followed
through with activism interaction and
you know Malcolm Jenkins is one of those
guys that is leading from the Sun and he
has his own deviation of a protest or
whatever you want to call it a
conversation piece and he's leading from
the song as you read up on the stuff you
got off the field I think it's admirable
and I think we need more people
I walk the walk and talk the talk and
you know the long weeks from you dan
white Nelson Charles not having those
funky people the reason why all that
hate gathers there is good I believe
that I the progressive City a city was
common sense that I've taken a step
store to right the wrongs of history and
people were feeling insecure and shut up
but for me I felt like I've always had
the duty and also for the comodo quality
but this week I thought maybe a symbolic
gesture might be what was calling it for
me personally and I first Malcolm and I
said I wanted to give you saw her I
don't want to step on your toes but uh
I've heard of support you and you being
a black male in America I could never
imagine what that feels like in the face
of this stuff but I'm here I'm here to
support you and gosh I mean you think
it's a simple gesture I don't think you
deserve a medal for making a simple
gesture that people have been positively
touched by it and I guess that's where
we are in discussion we'll just put an
arm around somebody which is not
something that takes that much effort
can make that much of a difference and I
hope oh and inspire some people to get
together on this thing and so after that
moment happened did you share word with
with Malcolm after the national anthem
was over I just always called him I
appreciate one giving me the opportunity
to supportive um you know because this
isn't something that I struggle with day
that as far as being the subject of that
hatred or you know
executional rinses on her white
supremacy it's not something that what I
deal with
and she allowed me to win their support
of the fear but meant something I just
think anything he you know although me
know Malcolm a couple months now and
certainly you know we're not best
offense but what he makes and what we're
developing a friendship you know have
him join the new team I think that's
what being on a team is about is each
other
and these conversations are important
and I wish everybody outside of
employers creaser but I wish everybody
when I came because you do get to hear
each other out
I'm excited to do through see Malcolm
lead from for the fun even more so in
person who is another legal couple more
minutes left here with Chris long of the
Philadelphia Eagles what do you say to
those in the stick to sports world where
you you are a football player and people
are tuning in to watch you play football
and be entertained by those skills and
don't want this conversation part of
their escapism watching football Chris
what do you say to those folks well I
mean fans have demanded to see more than
athletes right I mean that's where we
are in you know in 2017 and you want to
know more about your favorite players
you want to know about the personal life
we've got social media we place a lot of
pressure on players to be role models
not include sometimes tackling tough
issues that might be uncomfortable and
starting uncomfortable discussions and
yeah I'll never tell
fan on Twitter unless until fantastic I
just and you just stepped on or they do
for a living you know we can all talk
about the tough issues that are at hand
in our country right now and athletes
certainly only to be put in the box and
I will serve as a hydrant until there's
a difficult thing to do I don't think
it's a disease plays supporting it
you're supporting your fellow man and I
think that that's a bare minimum and
yeah I'm Haiti good and mostly they're
social some some positive so I don't act
like I'm really getting taken give you
an idea there are some people don't
that's a they don't know politics and
sports I don't remember
all-time one fighting white supremacy
was a political issue but uh
family there's for a couple people in
Wisconsin that's unfortunate yeah I'm
with you there's there's only one side
Chris there's only one side you know and
I'm glad to be on it with you and that
you're on that side and you know just
simple active just throwing your arm
around somebody and that moment says so
much it says so much about you says so
much about your team and it says so much
about our society that that does stand
out and I just wanted to say you know
way to go Central Africa Lawrence I mean
we're out of time but they I think
there's there's a lot of good people in
this country honey um you know and angle
and the reception kind of reaffirms God
nothing you know if everybody just
fights for unity funky fun comes to go
around on these tough issues and hear
each other out you know that's that's
why I hope that's why I stand for the
welcome and and that's why I love this
country and you can love this much
people are so quick as well
well look I look forward to the next
time I'll ask you all those pedestrian
questions like how's Carson Wentz doing
and how's the NFC's difference from the
AFA Steve awesome you know we could just
we could just do a deep dive into sports
next time Kris how does that sound
we will we will stick to sports
take care of yourself Kris really always
enjoy talking to you got it that's it
you bet that's Chris long at Joel nine
number nine one on Twitter the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy